So far in this course I've been treating
addresses as if they belong to hosts.
Well, they kind of do, but
it's more accurate to say
that addresses don't belong to hosts so
much as they belong to interfaces.
A host, like this laptop,
can have multiple network interfaces and
each interface can have zero or
more addresses.
For example, this laptop might have
a wired Ethernet interface and
a WiFi interface, and
every machine also has a loop
back interface which can be used for
talking to itself.
And there are other kinds
of interfaces as well, for
example you might have a tunnel
to another part of the network.
Or if you bring up a VM on a system,
like Virtual box for instance,
there can be a virtual machine interface
connecting the host operating system and
the guest operating system.
And on Linux you can find out
what interfaces your machine has
with the command ip addr show.
In this case showing that this
machine has a loopback interface and
eth0 interface, lo and eth0, and
here are their IPv4 addresses.
There are other commands
that can do this as well.
For instance on a Mac or other Unix
system, might use the ifconfig command.
And on Mac OS 10 you'll
find that a system has
an awful lot of interfaces,
many of which aren't used for
Internet traffic but for
other things like finding printers.
You can compare the addresses you see
here against your network configuration
in the GUI to find out what
interface you're actually using.
A little bit more about
that LOOPBACK interface.
The LOOPBACK is a special interface
that almost always has the IP
address 127.0.0.1 and
the host name localhost and allows
programs to use the network stack to
talk to other programs on the same host.
Whenever you've made connections
to local host or 127.0.0.1 before,
those are going over
the loopback interface.